es war der schlimmste kernkraftwerks
unfall der menschheit am 26 april 1986
explodierte der block 4 des kraftwerks
tschernobyl in der ukraine
jetzt in einem spezial klicks um science
and history
am 26 april 1986 schmilzt der kern im
block 4 des atomreaktors des typs
reaktor bolschoi motion ostsee kanal wie
in tschernobyl der reaktorkern lag frei
und brannte in der direkten umgebung und
in europa wurden die menschen erhöhter
radioaktivität ausgesetzt in der
nachbarstadt prypjat wurde die
bevölkerung 30 stunden lang stark
verstrahlt bis sie endlich dann
evakuiert wurde
in westeuropa ging man vollkommen
unbedarft mit der situation um
so ließen die veranstalter des riesigen
feuerwerk events rhein in flammen
hunderttausende menschen im radioaktiven
fallout also im radioaktivem regen
stehen alle verantwortlichen waren mit
dieser katastrophe vollkommen
überfordert es war ein super gau steht
dabei für den größten anzunehmenden
unfall eines kernkraftwerkes laute
einschätzung von atomphysiker zu beginn
der friedlichen nutzung der atomenergie
sollte es einen solchen unfall alle eine
million jahre geben es waren aber seit
dem beginn der energieerzeugung mit der
atomkraft mindestens acht kernschmelzen
ein solcher gau findet also alle zehn
jahre im schnitt statt
was war also in tschernobyl passiert ein
für die zulassung des reaktors
notwendiger test sollte mit drei jahren
verspätung endlich durchgeführt werden
er sollte gezeigt werden dass die
turbinen bei einem stromausfall und
gleichzeitigen abschalten des reaktors
noch genügend energie erzeugen um den
notbetrieb aufrecht zu erhalten in einer
solchen situation dauert es und so 30
bis 60 sekunden bis das notstromaggregat
läuft in dieser zeit muss die
verbliebene rotationsenergie der
turbinen die steuerungstechnik des
kraftwerks mit strom versorgen
diese turbinen werden mittels des heißen
wasserdampf der durch die hitze der
kernreaktion erzeugt wird angetrieben
bei abschaltung des reaktors und
gleichzeitigen stromausfall sind sie die
einzige chance noch ausreichend energie
für den notbetrieb zu erhalten diese
situation musste also bei diesem versuch
hergestellt werden dafür musste der
reaktor heruntergefahren werden
da es aber höheren strombedarf in der
ukraine gab musste der versuch
verschoben werden und der reaktor lief
länger in einem niedrigen
leistungsbereich
dadurch wurde neutronen absorbieren des
xenon 135 gebildet es beeinflusst die
leistung des reaktors massiv die bedien
mannschaft ahnte aber nichts von dieser
szene und vergiftung so nennt man das
unter atomphysiker oder zumindest nichts
vom umfang dieser vergiftung im vorfeld
des versuches geriet der reaktor dann
immer niedrigere und vor allem nicht
zugelassene leistungsbereiche durch das
xenon war der reaktor zudem nur sehr
schwierig zu steuern und das war fatal
in dieser situation wurde der test
begonnen und im wahrsten sinne des
wortes wurde eine kettenreaktion in gang
gesetzt sie nicht mehr zu stoppen war zu
beginn des versuchs wird mit dem
schließen von ventilen einen turbinen
die wärmeabfuhr des reaktors gestoppt es
kommt zu einem leistungsanstieg es
verdampft immer mehr wasser und
temperatur und leistung steigen weiter
und durch das xenon geschieht das noch
viel schneller die automatische reaktor
steuerung reagiert und fährt jetzt
steuerstäbe in den reaktor
diese bremsen normalerweise die
kernreaktion aber leider nicht sofort
das einfahren der stäbe die in dieser
situation viel zu langsam und
schichtleiter alexander a team of
aktiviert deshalb den havarie schutz
jetzt werden die steuerstäbe nicht mehr
eingefahren sondern abgeworfen
doch es war bereits zu spät und ein
konstruktiver nachteil der steuerstäbe
macht sich jetzt bemerkbar an den
spitzen der stäbe befindet sich graphit
das ist der moderator des reaktors
dieses graphit bremst die neutronen der
kernreaktion soweit ab dass mit dem uran
atomen überhaupt eine weitere
kernreaktion stattfinden kann und die
leistung steigt jetzt in
sekundenbruchteilen immer schneller
wahrscheinlich um das hundertfache genau
kann das heute niemand mehr sagen das
graphit fängt an zu brennen der kann
schmilzt und der reaktor explodiert
obwohl das reaktor dach weggesprengt
wird überall stücke von brennelementen
und steuerstäbe herumliegen wird nach
außen und selbst zur sowjetischen
regierung gemeldet der reaktor ist nicht
zerstört worden einen tag lang erhält
man diese version aufrecht außerhalb des
reaktors werden die brände gelöscht aber
erst einen tag später wird damit
begonnen die kettenreaktion und den
brand zu stoppen
dabei sind die helfertrupps
selbstmordkommandos zahlreiche helfer
sterben innerhalb von tagen an der
strahlenkrankheit unter dem reaktor wird
von außen ein neuer reaktor boden mit
einem stickstoff kühlsystem eingezogen
damit sich der reaktorkern nicht in den
boden brennen kann und dort gar nicht
mehr kontrolliert werden kann
die nachbarstadt prypjat wird erst jetzt
30 stunden nach der katastrophe
evakuiert zwei tage nach der havarie
kommt das unglück dann an die
öffentlichkeit im 1200 kilometer
entfernten schwedischen kernkraftwerk
forsmark wird alarm ausgelöst
die radioaktivität dort ist deutlich
erhöht doch in forsmark gibt es keine
störfall aufgrund der windrichtung ist
schnell klar es muss einen super gau in
der sowjetunion gegeben haben und jetzt
überschlagen sich die nachrichten am
abend des 28
april melden die sowjetischen medien
einen unfall und sprechen dann am 29
april von einer katastrophe es war jetzt
schnell klar was hier in westeuropa
getan werden musste
pilze dürften nicht mehr gegessen werden
gemüse musste vernichtet werden und aus
milch gewonnene molke war zum teil so
stark verstrahlt dass sie als
radioaktiver abfall eingelagert wurde
heute ist die radioaktivität gottseidank
zum größten teil abgeklungen und nur
noch in einigen gebieten süddeutschland
sind pilze noch stärker belastet aus den
atomkatastrophen hat man vielerorts
gelernt aber nicht überall was meint ihr
kernkraft ja oder nein
über eine angeregte diskussion freue ich
mich übrigens auch hier kunst organe aus
dem 3d drucker kunst vagina erfolgreich
implantiert
hier klicken und hier gehts zum blog mit
noch mehr wissenschaft allerdings
natürlich auch in der video beschreibung
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran